[Music]
thank you
out there and welcome to the uplift I'm
Tonya copel we've got a great show for
you today and a truly miraculous cast of
characters beginning with an army
veteran who literally rebuilt his life
after serving in Afghanistan what he
created by hand plus a dog with a job
how playing fetch prepared him for his
role and we'll take you on a historic
flight the very first of its kind for
the airline industry what made it so
special plus we bring you to a town that
has invested in a very unique sport any
guesses on what it might be here's a
hint it's slow
and we are going to celebrate a sports
icon I'm talking about sister Jean she
just reached a major Milestone we'll
have all of that plus our most
heartwarming videos the ones you just
gotta see you're watching The Uplift
[Music]
this is the uplift it's a show that
lifts you up for at least the next 30
minutes you and me as well I'm Toyota
and we're going to start by introducing
you to an inspiring Surfer who does not
look like anyone else out there on the
water take a look at Rosie
Rosie is a lab from California that has
been in the water and on the board since
she was basically a puppy she often goes
viral when she shows off her moves on
social media so we decided to wait on
the shore with Rosie and her owner to
get the story of this very talented and
tubular dog
when you look out over the ocean in
California you'll typically see some
Surfers but one Santa Cruz surfing
fanatic might Stand Out Rosie
Rosie's surfing partner Stephen drotter
said she got on a surfboard organically
she saw the family using paddle boards
on a lake so she jumped on Steve's he
eventually took her out into the ocean
where she proved she can hang ten hairy
toes I've been a surfer for four years
and I'd seen other people with dogs and
I always thought oh it'd be kind of cool
to have a dog to Surf with me I was
always kind of a dream I've had other
Labradors and they didn't want anything
to do with any surfboards but Rosie
clicked right to it Steve shares
countless videos of Rosie on social
media
spreads joy to more than a hundred and
thirty thousand people on Instagram
surfing has always been my release
you know it's been my my therapy to go
out and make myself feel feel calm and
ready to fight you know face the day and
surfing with her is you know the
greatest combination because I'm con you
know combining
my love for my dog and my love for
surfing so it's awesome and I can see
why people think it's cool and we love
sharing not only does she Inspire others
with her surfing but Steve says it's
beneficial to her too the dog likes to
be with me and do whatever I'm doing uh
she doesn't like it when I leave the
house without her and it's really kind
of a neat thing it's it's really a
teamwork when we're on the board
together we're working as a unit she's a
surfing star on social media and at the
beach we've got a loud into the lineup
uh if she's you know whether she's
surfing tandem on my sub or we're
paddling into waves or I'm pushing air
into waves the smiles that you see when
you come out there it's just oh my gosh
there's a dog and oh it's gross me she
catches a wave and you hear people
cheering go Rosie go I think this is fun
you know it gives it a different Dynamic
out there
Rosie might not be able to teach viewers
how to surf but she can instill
something in them for what a healthy
smile because I makes me smile and if
they were to take something away that's
what you can do with a dog you know what
you and your dog can do together besides
just sitting on the couch right you can
accomplish so much and those dogs are so
talented uh athletic and smart that you
know you can do so many things with them
that's satisfying for both of you
Rosie in the uplift have something in
common we both want to make people smile
and we hope our next story will LA's
Dodger Stadium was recently used for a
momentous occasion and sorry Baseball
fans I'm not talking about the game
talking about thousands of immigrants
who became U.S citizens all at the same
time jonathavigliotti met an 89 year old
whose Dream came true that day
you don't have to be a fan of baseball
to be moved by the emerald field of
America's national Pastime I don't
really know a lot about baseball but I
guess the Dodgers isn't my team now for
2100 people the Hallowed Ground of
Dodger Stadium was turned into a fitting
stage welcoming them as new citizens I
have to wait to get all the right visa
and forms to come through uh sorry it's
been a long time coming
um
from Europe Latin America and the
Caribbean Asia and Africa young and old
they pledge their allegiance on this
field of their dreams in the heart of
L.A please raise your right hand among
them the oldest new American in Los
Angeles today 89 year old Mona Lindo I'm
very excited it's Sunday too yeah who we
met last week ahead of her big day I'm
very very proud of my humbly beginning
but I really love America originally
from Jamaica she brought her young
family to LA in the 80s she says she
never felt the need to become a U.S
citizen at first but having eight
children and 41 Grand and
great-grandkids most of whom are now
American citizens change things how long
have you lived in the U.S for 42 years
42 years yeah why did you wait until now
I said I wanted to retire in Jamaica
make
but it became all my family
um decided to become a citizen so I made
the decision to get my
citizenship including her daughter Pam
she realizes what's going on you know
politically and she wants to be a part
of that process also I hereby declare on
oath I am very inspired she realized the
importance of it and stuck through it
seeing newly minted Americans never gets
old says United States citizenship and
Immigration Services director IR Mendoza
Jadu it is extremely special it has been
several years since we've been able to
do a big special events like like this
one and naturalize over 2 000 people
from 120 countries
congratulations if Mona Lindo has a
message for any other holdouts is that
when it comes to becoming an American
it's better late than never what's your
message to people watching this now who
may think I'm too old to try something
new what do you say to those people well
it's never too late I most think about
living than dying so I continue with my
life wherever it takes me
love that story it's more than just a
piece of paper Jonathan thank you very
much all right take a look at this next
video which proves that you really can't
do anything if you put your mind to it
mom hit the pause button great
no
hmm
I can't when you get there close your
eyes and just jump
close your eyes and think of nothing and
jump
like this you can do it
okay okay
yeah you did it
all right Bravo we're all rooting for
you it's nicely done uh that's a
heartwarming video and we're gonna have
more of our heartwarming videos
throughout our show and you can catch
them anytime by the way on Facebook that
is facebook.com uplift news
all right coming up they are still
family two actors who used to play
husbands on TV recently shared a funny
moment on social media we'll show you
that viral video
plus do you know sister Jean she is a
nun and she is a very special person in
the world of sports and she just reached
a major Milestone her story after the
break
[Music]
welcome back to the uplift time now for
the heartwarming videos the ones you
just gotta see and we're gonna start
with this one
but you
happy birthday
to you
happy birthday dear peanut and baby
happy birthday to you
peanut and Benny that's their names and
they are siblings not just friends
however they were adopted by separate
families about nine months after they
left the pet store their families met at
a dog park park just by chance and at a
certain point they realized that their
pups were not just good buddies they
were long lost relatives
siblings every year now they celebrate
their birthday together and the one
you're looking at on your screen that is
birthday number 13. they even had a bark
mitzvah
hold for Applause all right our next
video shows three-year-old Hadley seeing
her mom and new baby brother for the
first time after her mom gave birth
you brought brother a present
hi hi
I'm so gentle hi hi thank you I miss you
hello indeed very sweet story there all
right A Bride named Devon was trying on
wedding dresses dresses recently when
she came out of the dressing room and
got a big surprise take a look
hey I made it hi
Mommy
oh so sweet she didn't think her mom was
going to be able to make it because they
don't live in the same state but Mom
traveled from Florida or to Florida
rather from North Carolina just to be
there for that big moment trying on
those dresses and to surprise her
daughter who definitely was surprised
Mommy
all right Modern Family actors Jesse
Tyler Ferguson and Eric Stonestreet
played husbands on TV it's a great show
and they are still friends and still
being funny together this is what
happened when Stone Street got to meet
his TV husband's son Beckett for the
first time
sand we could put sand in here what else
could we put in a dump truck
manure
yeah do you know what manure is
yes there's been yep
manure yes when I leave what I will have
taught you is the word manure
what is it about kids that age and uh
trash trucks dump trucks they love them
big trucks a lot of books on my shelf
with that topic all right coming up meet
an army veteran who faces PTSD but then
started rebuilding his life and I mean
quite literally I'll tell you what he
created by hand
plus the dog with a unique job fit for a
canine we will tell you what it is after
the break
have you heard of sister Jean if you're
a fan of college basketball you probably
have she's a big deal in that world she
is chaplain of Loyola University's men's
basketball team and she just turned
103 the balloons were right the nun is
known as loyola's biggest fan and she
became a household name back in 2018
during the team's impressive
head-turning run in the NCAA tournament
that year to honor the Super Fan for her
big birthday Chicago mayor Lori
Lightfoot issued a proclamation making
August 21st 2022 sister Jean Dolores
Schmidt day here is what she had to say
about reaching 103.
well I think it's because first of all I
eat well I pray well I hope I pray and I
sleep well now work with you all the
time and that actually keeps me going
because I have to know what the latest
language is and all that kind of thing
and so young people like to be here
[Music]
eat well pray well secrets to a long
life you heard it here first also last
most dogs moving on to our next story
they like to play fetch but a dog named
Ripken is not just in it for a game for
him it is a job here's Chris Van Cleave
the 1988 hit Bull Durham was a major
Home Run for the minor league Durham
Bulls
it's a dog
barking for more
meet Ripken the bat dog I actually
sometimes have to apologize to the
players because they'll ground out to
Second and all of a sudden the crouches
goes crazy
for this six-year-old black lab playing
cleanup collecting the bats for the
hometown team and ripken's also a good
luck charm for Bulls outfielder miles
Master boning do you worry people will
say that you're just letting the game go
to the dogs
foreign
no not at all actually assistant general
manager chip Allen says the team did
have a couple canine concerns with the
bats come back
wet would they have teeth marks in it
and I don't know how Ripken does it no
saliva on the bats no teeth marks it
helps his owner Michael O'Donnell is a
dog trainer and former college baseball
player we started with just kind of
playing Fetch with bats in the backyard
and having fun how did you get the dog
to ignore all of the balls on the field
lots of practice letting O'Donnell live
out his baseball dreams through his
four-legged best friend
while hoping the big leagues throw
Ripken a bone sometime soon
yeah he's a good dog all right moving on
to our next story after serving in
Afghanistan one man found himself like
so many others broken down but he soon
started rebuilding his life by hand and
I mean so literally Roxanna saberi has
his story
Allen came to the mountains of Wales
searching for solitude
so this is it yeah this is the castle
I've been building now for the last
three years
but he found purpose
after serving with the British army in
Afghanistan over a decade ago Allen
suffered from post-traumatic stress
disorder his marriage broke down and one
day so did he just kept eating
painkillers and eating them and eating
them
the hope not to wake up
but she woke up
I woke up the next day he was homeless
but a farming family let him live and
build on their land his castle became
his salvation Wilderness has been a big
coping mechanism for myself but in the
meantime I guess it is great and
something for other people each week
local residents and other troubled
veterans visit inspired by the 42 year
old whose charity index offers Fitness
sessions skills training and counseling
with therapists like Gareth Noble as bad
as things are there's always a future
the belief is important Alan hopes to
finish the Castle's third and final
floor this fall more space for more
healing
nice Sudan Roxanna saberi coming up you
may see more Runners Out Racing during
the summer but one small city in
Minnesota puts on a very different kind
of race stick around find out what it is
plus we're going to take you on a
historic flight it is the first time
anything like it has happened in 96
years the reason for this momentous
occasion will tell you after the break
thank you
welcome back to the uplift we are going
to take you now to the small city of
Parham it's in Minnesota and we're going
to go there to show you their Sports
Arena it's not what you're going to
expect John lordson has more
we're known for a laid-back type of life
laid-back lifestyle laid back is a great
way to describe the city of pearl
at least six days out of the week
because on Wednesdays Turtles out of the
bucket nose behind
your town has
45 years ago we started racing Turtles
uh in the alleyway behind the post
office and it's evolved over the years
part of that Evolution meant moving from
the alleyway to the Courtyard behind the
Chamber of Commerce that's where you'll
find an arena where the Inner Circle
serves as the starting line and the
Outer Circle serves as the Finish Line
it was ever Turtle gets to the outside
Circle first is the winner the zoo you
want to do both of them this time we
call it the international turtle races
because we do have international Racers
every year just last week we had a
family from Germany here racing Turtles
and they they absolutely love it Smiles
ear to ear they get anywhere from 200 to
500 racers in the middle of the week
only painted turtles are allowed to ring
that's the best one competitors can pick
a turtle when they arrive and the
strategy is pretty simple we just look
at which ones are trying to like get out
of the buckets and stuff but some kids
like 12 year old Bryce Olson we're not
going to research one this time raise
their own Turtles he's been racing since
he was two he's like the Richard Petty
of turtle races so some Bowlers bring
their own bowling balls to the bowling
alley you bring your own
turtles yeah reaching speeds of up to a
quarter mile an hour the races last
anywhere from 30 seconds to two minutes
depending on how motivated the turtles
are this is like NASCAR except for at a
much slower slower
slower Pace yeah you could probably add
about six or seven more slowers to that
all right here we go
once that whistle blows there's truly a
Need for Speed or at least a
medium-paced Meandering of sorts look at
your guy Bryce what are you feeding that
guy 45 straight years of photo finishes
for Purim it's been a good run or crawl
whatever you want to call it
thank you
reaching speeds of a quarter mile an
hour I love it that's a delightful story
thank you John from Minnesota there all
right a first of its kind flight
recently took off from the city of
Phoenix here in these United States and
our Chris Van Cleave has more on the
powerful meaning behind the flight
this American Airlines ground crew is
prepping flight 372 for a trip into the
history books it's the first time in the
airline's 96 years everyone involved
from the ramp to the gate we are honored
to have you on board in the cockpit and
in the cabin
are all black women the flight
celebrates the 100th anniversary of
Bessie Coleman the first
African-American woman to earn a pilot's
license Coleman had to learn to fly in
France because it wasn't an option here
in the U.S
her great niece Gigi was on the
celebration flight well my great aunt
received her license two years before
Amelia Earhart she wasn't in the history
books no one knew about her
she runs the Bessie Coleman Aviation
All-Stars an after-school program aimed
at inspiring kids especially young
people of color to take flight now I've
never had an all-black female flight
crew in my entire career there are fewer
than 150 black women airline pilots in
the U.S Captain Beth Powell is one of
the representation is so important today
because when you see someone in yourself
you know it's possible I can do this too
sharing the story of Bessie Coleman in
hopes of inspiring the pilots of
tomorrow
well look if you're not inspired by that
if you're not uplifted by our show I
tell you what here's the deal for you go
back to the beginning you can watch the
whole thing again no charge just for you
that's our show I do hope it brightened
your day I do hope it lifted you up come
back next time on the uplift I'm gonna
go look for some good stories
[Music]